so here i am at Heathrow and as you can
see outside it's sort of almost dawn I'm
just pleased the days here actually
because there's been a lot of prep to
get to this point you have to realized
as well this was a year since I got back
from Ethiopian almost of the day so it
seems sort of fitting that you know the
same day I got back a year later I'm
flying out so hopefully get people to
take notice
we're on our way to da boss which take
it's night one in Davos and as you can
see it's absolutely beautiful snowing
gently years really crystal clear and
fresh and it's just absolutely amazing
and actually what springs to mind for me
is the juxtaposition with my Ethiopia
experience and what I wonder is some of
the world leaders who are here they must
spend a lot of their lives talking about
poverty but have they ever actually
experienced it they ever actually gone
into slums and seeing how people live
and I suppose that's what is on my mind
at the moment is really holding those
girls voices and those African
experiences with me here as we go
forward I'm about to an interview on CNN
so that hopefully will go global so the
message is getting out female genital
mutilation calmly known as FGM is an
ancient custom often tied to religious
and social acceptance and now Julia Lala
Maharaj is bringing it to the attention
of leaders of the world economic forum
in davos my belief is that issues like
this can't stay on the margins that they
really have to be debated at the highest
levels it's the end of day one it's been
a really long day and I'm a proud owner
of a white badge it's just quite
phenomenal in Davos it basically means
access for every yes but today's been a
setup
so it's really tomorrow morning where
everything happens it'll be talking with
people it will be working out how to
save to them about female genital
mutilation in a way that makes someone
to listen so yeah a good day and I'm
looking forward to tomorrow but um i'll
let you know how it goes
you